hi guys I'm Greg I'm John so we finally
saw the movie split split we have this
segment called how it could work where
we take sequel ideas reboots remakes
whatever it's a hypothetical movie we're
going to beat it out yeah you how it
could work and we we beat out the whole
thing so we spent like hours working on
an unbreakable two concept prior to the
release of split it took us like several
days ago tracks yeah Cory bring up
details when I was like an hour long of
us just telling the story that we came
up with from beginning to end yeah and
people were like yeah you really should
watch what it should because I as in the
back that there's no Kevin in here is uh
is not a real unbreakable tip and before
we go into her split the spoiler ending
discussion I just want to say that I
think our story could still work uh yeah
it could be like what what David does
prior to him learning of Kevin yeah yeah
all that has to be I don't think and I
don't know I haven't read any deeper
into the comments of the whole like ah
you guys need to see split like I don't
think that's necessarily saying it can't
worry I think it's just people being
like there's more context guys yeah I
wishing is fairly I agree 15 years later
we haven't universe one other David
doesn't sort here that happened as ours
Ryerson yeah this is what the exact
releases this is what David Dunne was
doing this whole time and this is maybe
going to open the door for them to come
together I think our story then a split
unbreakable hydrant what totally beep
off about yeah I was like what are
people talking about night oh cool if
you just did this one on horn we got an
idea just for you and hey we'll cut you
a discount
yeah no cut you a discount yeah $200 you
all we ask people Adsense for the movie
anyway now that we got that little rant
off our show yeah let's talk about the
ending of this movie so the ending of
split we don't listen here's what we'll
say about how we feel about the film any
good review you heard that's probably
exactly what we would say yeah to put it
out there bluntly all right we go nor
did he's really talking everything it's
intriguing and it's unsettling and James
not really well travel
yeah there's a few moments of stiff
dialogue rather than that's really cool
and the ending is I will say leading
into the ending talk of like we've been
doing this whole time without knowing
that this is linked to unbreakable I I
know some people had issues with him
like developing the super strength and
becomes the beast climbing up the walls
and [ __ ] some people had issues of
economic because it is a little bit out
of the realm of what this movie's world
has established like they didn't allude
to any of that being a possibility yet I
always think those are interesting like
these kinds of candidates is kind of a
sci-fi movie when you really talk about
it yeah I feel like sci-fi movies like
these often come to a point where they
take a leap and it's a matter of is that
leap too big or too little it's like you
know we go a little further into the
future we're on the precipice of
something and so for this movie I
thought they did it pretty well I liked
it when it happened they kept it down to
earth and they they at least explained
the idea and the phenomenon of like oh
his brain is evolving and it's evolved
in such a way that it's creating its own
design yes I'm Kayli literally changes
his chemistry when the Hofstra cream
bodies and I'm like this that is totally
sci-fi not too far over the realm of
reality yeah why are we like study like
these kinds of things you know well yeah
when you see the the beast you know he's
he's just sort of jacked and animalistic
like he is just another version of this
guy who is again heightened you know I
think it would have been really weird if
he came back is like that big black
demon guy yeah but like the way they did
it here is he gets just kind of huge
yeah and primal in my own personal life
I am one of those people who believes in
this into belief of that you can become
whoever you want and what you want to do
based off your based off what you
believe you are what you can't achieve
I'm saying that if there was someone out
there who believes he can become like
that straw and he actually really
believed it yeah like I don't believe
that I'm not at a level in my life yet
where I can believe that about me but if
there was someone I met who just like
you just [ __ ] movies many achieves it
I'll be like well yeah he believes ahead
so he achieved it you know yeah well
these movies both have that sort of
thread of belief yeah and you know
because any things you can realize and
actualize when you believe even if you
look at the movie unbreakable David Dunn
learns that he can't actually activate
any of these powers and what he believes
he can
do it first yeah till he ponders about
like even though like the weightlifting
see me like I thought he can only lift a
certain amount he had a hard time of it
yeah but the more he kept believing he
could do more he could he suddenly could
do we really not this movie it falls in
the same category of how belief shapes
who we are it's the same themes and
that's when I started seeing like the
unbreakable similarity now as far as the
ending to talk good about it I think the
concept and knowing that it's part of
the same unbreakable universe and that
this could be a potential villain for
the next like unbreakable installment
they make I think is really cool I love
the idea I love the idea of the secret
sequel or secret spin-off you know
without letting the audience know up
front and trailers and marketing that
this is in the same world I think is
brilliant and it's exciting for us
because people have one annum breakable
to for so long that this is a great way
to do it
what's and surprise to like surprise see
a suprise origin story actually is
really nice yeah absolutely
because it gives you a chance to go in
cold and get an intrigued again in a way
you couldn't so like that's that's a
special part of this for me so yeah like
really bringing in and going this is
unbreakable was like a cool treat that I
wish I had no idea about when I went
into this exactly because I didn't know
if this was going to link directly into
unbreakable I just know it started a
conversation about unbreakable two
throughout the movie I had it in the
back of my mind yeah but even so it
doesn't get in the way of everything I
think that's nice like it yeah it is a
nice sort of unfolding of that story
yeah and I know that lonoa David Dunn is
this is the same world of unbreakable
that made people easier to latch on to
the fact that he is the beat that he
could achieve these level of like
superhuman strength as well but what I
will say though I didn't want to weigh
if it's done I just did it like I loved
I feel like and I love everything about
including it it's just the way it was
put in was like I didn't really like
that scene it felt like a scene out of a
different movie almost and the actress
well--we're daily are hey he hasn't won
his name there are another guy they name
- yeah it felt like a and I kept a bad
post-credit marble scene or something
like that
yeah I could really feel it telling me
like like this the thing is that scene I
feel like could
works free easily if they just treated
it with a little more of a natural tone
like if you just pan if you tracked it
down the bar and just kind of heard what
each person was talking about and then
you got to that yeah we just have to
people like it wasn't it didn't have it
like it wasn't there another guy who had
a name and yeah like you could tuck it
in there really easily but it's like
it's so on the note it wasn't done in a
natural way yeah it didn't fit with the
rest of the movie at the point so I like
that it smashes the black and then they
have this extra scene because I'm like I
kind of consider the scene everything
before that the complete movie yeah yeah
yeah and then you have this like it's
like before the credits but it's like a
post-credits scene that's like it's a
tiny gripe but I feel like it it almost
would have played better with that gap
yeah you know and so I'm not upset at
all that it's linked to him like like a
key wanna make this clear I really happy
that it's part of your breakable world I
think it's really what a night Shyamalan
did especially setting up the villain
yeah the original I'm tagging is for
unbreakable four and I wrote them out
like really getting to know this villain
of with brilliant concept I'm really
excited to see when they do cross paths
yeah I'm really excited to see that when
that has happened it's just the way the
scene was executed it was my only gripe
about it yeah that was the one thing I
was like I really the only thing I
really have an issue is the head of the
whole movie
yeah well cuz you know like tacking it
on to the very end of the movie makes it
read like a piece of a whole entire
movie yeah whereas like I would have
been more forgiving if it was on its own
yeah maybe they do shots as later or
something it is a given yeah but I liked
seeing Bruce Willis it's exactly that
it's like if they just toned it a little
differently I think it would have been
really cool yeah and it is really cool
and again I like so much about
unbreakable that there are a lot of
different genre elements in it
unbreakable tipped into horror a few
times for me like some of those crime
sequences and when he's like first
fighting off that dude in the house like
those are actually tense
yeah don't horror centric well even the
beginning with the train sequence and
everything is read like a horror film
and so to swing more to that side of the
spectrum for the villain I think is
actually really cool because this weird
little superhero I guess if you want to
call it that you know universe becomes
fascinating to me in that way because
it's it's more broad thematically out
I'm excited for when they do cross paths
I wouldn't mind another unbreakable
movie that doesn't have Kevin just yet
honestly I would want to see like
another adventure and David like I kind
of feel like I wouldn't want this to
just be a trilogy well and I also like
the time passage I think is part of it -
yeah it's like a big time gap yeah it's
like you made unbreakable and it's been
like 16 years yeah we just met Kevin I
feel like we have to check back in with
David done before we smash them together
exactly because then I feel like you
might have a balance issue to with
balancing out date I don't know tonight
has a grand idea I know you attempt to
have a small outline right now and
breakable and split or two of his
greatest films he's done so I'm sure he
has a great idea for how to mesh meet
you together does my frequency thoughts
are like will it really be executed in a
way where I feel like we get the right
amount of screen time for both well I
feel like the thing that gives me hope
for this is the thing the the quote from
him where he basically said like
unbreakable I wanted to be his own piece
split is his own piece in the third
movie I want to be its own piece yeah
I'm not going and that gives me faith if
they only do three like ideally I would
love another David Dunn movie kind of
like our movie yeah just because now we
can spend some time with these
characters here and now right before
they collide exactly but knowing that he
wants to do something distinct with the
third one - hey I'm open now like he's
he's done well enough recently that I'm
open to seeing what he's going to do
because I think he can do it you know I
know he's in saying he wants his next
somebody shoots to be this movie I would
like him to do one more break how am I
going to do one more film though yeah
show that he can just still mix it up
and then go back and do this you know
not just me and go into split
unbreakable you just got back on the
good graces with the visit yeah you got
people really excited with split yeah
take a second before you do your French
I yeah
well guys what do you think of the split
ending you'll like it you'll like it a
lot did you watch our video probably not
it's an hour long if you stick around
for the whole video we love you
subscribe to the reel rejects today John
is reason for Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram he's also a social media
manager facebook.com slash the real
rejects and he's the social media
manager of the sites that produced split
and sure you
look how blum house left the house for a
glum house yes people give you time I
shouldn't blue man Blanc house most
people do but it edge jason said he says
Jason Blum he's seen it wrong